ladies and gentlemen from Rolling Stone
oh they're seething over this Oliver
Anthony's populist polarizing rich men
north of Richmond on track to debut at
number one the Virginia upstart song
about rich politicians and poor people
abusing welfare is already Atop The
iTunes Spotify and apple music charts
he's got what are they saying 98 000
digital song sales 7.8 million streams I
don't know uh where that'll put him on
the hot 100. it is very it is very uh
difficult to uh to to top that sharp but
they say Morgan wallen's last night the
reigning number one from this week's
Billboard Chart and one of the biggest
hits of the year has 13 million streams
but just over 3 000 digital sales with
41 million AirPlay Impressions it's a
major year for the genre blah blah blah
all right so let's let's break this down
I could be wrong in my math but I
believe that one sale is 1 500 streams
so do the math and you'll calculate how
many streams uh that uh Oliver Anthony
actually has but that 41 million
AirPlay Impressions that's hard to beat
yeah that's basically the radio station
saying we'll play your music and of
course they're not gonna get Oliver
Anthony on there it's going to be very
difficult now with the weight of the
song they might be forced to oh yeah but
you know why he's uh you know I have a
real simple reason
why this song's doing so well and why
they're so mad about it
what did the corporate music industry
give us in terms of music
wet ass
yeah okay that's the stuff that they
tell you to listen to okay fine Adele is
up there somewhere and Taylor Swift and
then you have that teeny bopper stuff
from Harry Styles or whatever it's not
only just WAP or whatever but this is
the antithesis of WEP
so this is something that regular people
who are sick of the disgusting Sodom and
Gomorrah music and entertainment
industry can now be like hey there's
some music hey I understand this hey
these words mean something to me and
that's pushing back so this you combine
it with all the other cultural Endeavors
we've been winning on and
just feels good you know what I thought
was fascinating you you put the headline
up from Rolling Stone for the first I
don't know maybe 24 48 72 hours he was a
phenomena everybody was excited and then
once the folks from the right John rich
and others sort of talked about him and
made him a Cause
the the Rolling Stones of the world
suddenly branded them it was like oh God
we we were initially positive on this
guy the second that people on the right
embraced him
what's the headline polarizing he was
polarizing in Q Anon because but for the
first 24 hours he was a rock star and
you know a savant and you know this it
was but it was so funny to watch how
quickly they shifted once folks on the
right embraced the message and his
success they're like if you guys like
him we hate it exactly there's nothing
to do I mean I for one love to see
Ginger representation I think redheads
don't have enough uh place in the media
uh yeah I feel like we should credit him
as a representing a very
um uh minority genetic group yes thank
you sir uh but I think part of it too is
at least for me again this is the sort
of the alternative country folk genre
that I personally already like uh but I
think he's talented right we so much of
what's sort of AstroTurf right now in
pop pop music is just like the same one
verse with one Bridge it's all kind of
electronically done and maybe those
singers and artists and songwriters have
some Talent on some level but because
it's supposed to appeal to the masses
they try to make it as simple and as you
know your wormy as possible whereas this
is actually catchy he's actually got a
good voice he's actually a talented
musician and that's more effective
instead of sort of trying to make it
this garbage song giving something
something with giving the people
something with feeling is really having
an impact so I have a correction it's
not 1500 it's 150. for every sale of
Richmond north of Richmond that counts
as 150 streams
so he's currently sitting at uh with
with these numbers
yeah we're looking at about
22.5 million streams
he's not going to beat this these other
radio uh radio guys now he would you
know beat this up the song only has 13
million streams and 3 000 sales that
ain't nothing but they've got the radio
behind them so I can only tell you this
man if you really like the song you all
need to go on iTunes and buy it if that
and tell all your friends to buy it
because if you're going to listen to it
if and look we've talked about it with
our music and everything but I'm gonna
say this right now I know you all love
this song I love this song it's a great
song I was I had planning on Loop early
I was like damn this song's fantastic
buy it spend that dollar buy it go on
iTunes buy the song tell all your
friends to buy the song anyone you know
who listens to it you say hey man let's
make this guy the Superstar let's make
him bigger than than cardi B bigger than
Taylor Swift all you got to do is spend
a dollar that one dollar counts as 150
streams let's get this song to debut
Platinum I think he needs uh 75 to 150 I
think he needs 150 million he needs he
needs just about eight times where he's
currently at in terms of streams and
purchases so right now they're all
seething they're trying to argue that
he's a plant yes look at this
intelligence intelligence or look at
this Oliver Anthony and the incoherence
of right-wing populism they're losing
their mind over a factory worker termed
farmer who wrote a country Acoustic Song
it didn't do anything to anybody he
wrote a song about how he feels and they
are losing their minds but this gets
back to the Bud Light the target uh
right in the last 24 months give or take
I I feel like conservatives have gotten
their sea legs we go out there and go
guess what we're not going to take it
we're not going to shop or we're not
gonna buy you and then conversely sound
of Freedom Oliver Anthony we go out
there and go all right we support them
this is what's I think we have finally
starting to get get it together you
actually don't want like something then
stop going into the store stop buying
the product don't just say ugh the heck
with it and for the things that we do
like and Tim you're absolutely right you
go out you spend that buck at some point
they can't ignore it and that's what
happened with sound of freedom and and
frankly before that the Chosen and I
know they've got a bunch more in the
works at Angel Studios but that's what's
happening with this guy as well it's a
dollar to make a difference and that's
what's going on is I I just I get
excited when I see success stories like
this because it just shows that we can
do it and I think that's frankly what's
going on in media too I tell people all
the time go look at what you guys are
doing at Tim Cask look at what Patrick
but David's doing all of these folks
that the media doesn't want to pretend
exist are unbelievably successful and
that's why I'm doing what I'm doing it's
like you know what I'm tired the
corporate stuff it's it's not where the
future is anymore and I think if we band
together and support each other when
events like this come along this is
where I think we start to win again
I love uh Oliver Anthony's performance I
think that that song is pretty simple
it's like a verse course Verse Chorus
and it's just ends after that so there's
no Bridge there's no three parts that
you would consider to make a hit but the
way he performs it is so real visceral
less is more it changes you and like
it's the kind of thing where he could
tell you a bedtime story and it would be
invigorating because of the way he tells
it post Malone's like that this guy's
like post Malone's got the posty energy
I love it he needs one million sales to
be platinum you need 150 million streams
for platinum I hope I hope this song
gets there yeah it's like the biggest
song in the world so where's he at right
now what's the 20 some odd million and
98 000 sales so he's at 10 of the sales
needed look debuting at Platinum is a
big ask songs songs go platinum after
like a few years then they're like hey
you finally reach that you cross that
Mark where you know you've you've got
enough plays of your song but it would
be cool if he could do it because he
seems like someone who has strong values
I mean he posted earlier today that he's
uh launching you know merch for for this
with a local t-shirt company from
wherever he's from in Virginia like
Farmville I think that's cool Farmville
Farmville May's from Farmville yes and
now you understand why people like plant
you know what I mean uh no we live in a
simulation but I I like that he is
saying like I I want to support other
small businesses and I think that is
cool to see it would be very easy for
him to be like people want my stuff let
me figure out the fastest way to get to
them or the big Corporation they can
help me out and I wouldn't I I would
understand why you would do it I just
like that he's opting to work locally
and small that's a value that I would
want to see in my own life
check this out they say uh Fox News
Oliver Anthony says he's turned down
eight million dollar offer since going
viral nothing special about me yeah dude
stay independent brother all right just
I will Roger up if you want to give me
eight million dollars um
cancel your show it's not worth it if
you saw me dance my singing's worse than
that uh dude I I listened to his song
like four or five times this rich man of
north of Richmond and it was like the
fifth time I listened to it something
struck me like I just started shaking I
was like I got Goosebumps all through my
body for like almost the entire song but
sometimes that's what it takes a few
times you listen to something or you eat
something a few times and it's a fire
taste it's real music yeah so much music
because we've been putting out music Let
Me Explain you guys we talked to these
industry dudes and they say you gotta
get on the dsps the Digital streaming
playlists once you're there they'll
automatically play your song for people
if it's in a certain genre and then
you'll start getting play and I'm like I
get it if you're in the machine if you
are approved by the people who work for
Pandora for Spotify or whatever if
you're well known they'll Auto load your
new song it will be guaranteed to get a
certain number of hits and then you're
going to chart yeah all the stuff we had
to do when we released Songs and we
charted was asking people to to to to
like hey be active listen to our music
so we're fighting through this machine
that props up everybody else Oliver
Anthony has hit the dream
he has 17 million hits on you on YouTube
000 sales the equivalent of about 15
million 14 uh 14 million 700 000. so
he's looking at 30 plus million streams
all organically with no industry support
because he wrote a good song that
resonates with people yeah nailed it
yeah it's awesome and I look I mean it's
got 19 million on YouTube now Millions
three million in one day radio WV where
I saw this video originally does stuff
with other artists like he sort of I
hope he does well individually I don't
want to take attention away from him but
like
he is representational of a whole
group of artists who probably don't get
the attention from mainstream Outlets
because they are not exactly what
they're looking for and I think it's
cool to have someone who's sort of
opening the door and saying you know it
feels like it becomes that thing if you
like this music you can probably figure
out other artists that you can support
that are similar to him and I think Tim
you mentioned that he didn't have
industry support but I think he has an
industry support it's just a new kind of
industry it's a decentralized Creator
industry yeah like Jack kosovic people
that fire out his music to 100 000 views
I think I think the video is actually
posted to some kind of
Music Channel yeah it is
right it's small I mean there's another
one
um I think it's called gemstone VHS like
if you like this style of music you can
kind of find it but I think you're not
entirely wrong it's not like the mega
big Studio or I can't even it's very
different you might be well known your
genre you might grow but I don't know of
anyone else who sort of launched this
stardom from these smaller groups thanks
for watching this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time